[Music]
all right does uh
everybody remember this
yeah oh nirvana yeah yeah
a baby everybody know who that guy is no
who is it
is that really baby in a pool by the way
that didn't do anything to that that is
really a baby wow
he has penis his name is spencer elvin
including us
do you know why mr spencer is uh
relevant today why a headline that he's
suing he is suing pornography nirvana is
being sued by the baby from the never
mind album oh what why so take a guess
take a guess money why else non-consent
photography that that's the line right
it's the uh the parents never signed a
release authorizing the use of his image
on the album says him and his legal
counsel where are these parents at
i don't know i also alleges that the
nude images constitute child
pornography even though it explicitly
states that a naked child is not
alluding to that but he's his legal
accounts saying because there's money in
it
because there's literally oh my god
isn't it his fault for being naked in
that photo yeah put some clothes on
concept well he shouldn't have been a
hooker then how about that wow
i'm gonna just spew out a couple more
facts because i think this is really
funny look at him chasing that money
greedy ass [ __ ] it comes full circle i
understand the legal system but
sometimes i wish i was a judge just so i
could go to like hey come here laura let
me let me talk to you in the back yeah i
just [ __ ] slap them like 20 times i
wish that hammer was not only a gobble
for this but you could chuck it at the
person like four
and it comes back to you
that's a real judge put [ __ ]
because that gavel only can only be
picked up by one person
and then it crushes the whole [ __ ]
right trip oh yeah that's true i guess
two people could do it so far spoiler
alert yeah this guy hasn't watched end
game yet because he's [ __ ] wait what
he had a kid this guy's spending all the
time watching like jackie chan you know
i love jackie chan he don't watch
adventures not yet
he likes rumble in the bronx right now
he wants
that that means by the time he gets to
avengers is gonna be 30 years old
they're still stuck in the 80s and 90s
right now they have to work their way up
that's cool though well it's because
like there's too much talking and marvel
stuff so he'll like he'll like get out
of here so there's an actual story oh
it's better with jackie because his
english is second language as well and
he's like so animated and it's like it's
action so like the beats come really
really fast so he's like he's so crazy
he gets the power rangers oh dude power
rangers but jackie's like stabbing
people with forks and [ __ ] yeah
not until the foreigner but he kind of
regrets it he always goes oh no oh don't
want trouble yeah okay all right he says
it before so it's all good
so he claims that he has suffered and
will continue to suffer lifelong damages
as a result of the artwork including
extreme and permanent emotional disorder
nobody even knows who the [ __ ] he is
so vague this is what his lawyer told
him yeah asking for damages of at least
150 000 from each of the 15 defendants
that's a good person good little bag how
many members who includes surviving band
members dave girl and
chris is it chris nova select kurt
cobain's gondola the managers of kurt
cobain's estate kobe's former wife
courtney love and photographer kirkwood
the wife he's going after everybody this
was a paris dude you know he should just
sue his parents but you know what's even
funnier guess who this is him
why is he doing that oh he's doing
recreation because he does it every 10
years and he's done it every 10 years
he's a cuck bro wow
his
sean white should cop should sue him for
looking like sean white yeah [ __ ] that
right there's only one sean white out
coffee white
coffee coffee white you can't be
copyrighting
dude that's gross so wait so he plays
into it he's he likes it he likes the
attention and then he needs money so he
does this
that's weird man do you think he'll get
people like that
if he gets it i think he deserves like
god to curse him and he drowns in the
pool we're very open-minded here yeah
that's full circle i think yeah that is
that is truly funny on his next photo
shoot to celebrate the album he should
die oh damn and that he should get the
money
because you know child porn is wrong so
he should be compensated for that and
then he should die and then all the
money should go to protecting
children so you think that he's doing
the photo and then they throw a pool
cover on
damn seal it
that'll do it that'll be good
you know the bubbles that they the
bubble thing that they cover the pool
with so you don't yeah
bubble wraps
it looks like bubble wrap that they just
unwrap on the board but it's pretty
heavy i guess it's just tarp yeah but
he's so dumb he can't climb out of it
yeah he you know though he totally talks
about all the doors that it opened for
him being the nirvana baby you know i
mean he literally says uh it was always
a positive thing open doors for me i'm
23 and an artist at this time and it
gave me the opportunity to work with
shepard ferry for five years which was
an awesome experience
huge music connoisseur
and when he heard i was the nirvana baby
he thought it was really cool
so it's kind of like
there's clear winds to it and at the end
of it i guess if you can get over the
fact that like everybody in the world
has seen your penis when you're an
infant dude everyone sees your penis
when you're a baby it's a baby's penis
dude yeah what happened to honor
you know you know before it's like even
before looking at what the rules are
it's like
all right this is just some things that
are kind of weird i'm not going to even
do
just to okay let's try it first let's
try devil's advocate let's say this guy
is at every party yeah and they're like
yo a little baby dick guy's here
oh that is pretty embarrassing that
would be
because he's like the nirvana baby he's
a lot of baby guys how many how many
but then shouldn't he be suing those
guys we're talking [ __ ]
yeah
instead of going the other way shouldn't
he be like taking a photo with his dick
out by the way and all these updated
pictures like why isn't he doing that he
needs to return all the girls that he
got laid with she needs to return this
yeah he needs to return all the money
that he got everything that he benefited
it's a good line i'm the nirvana baby
you want to [ __ ] yeah ooh the good line
because you know
dude it's like because then they could
be like you know who i [ __ ] the
nirvana baby yeah who did you [ __ ]
recently yeah right steve from
accounting yup i [ __ ] little debbie yo
i [ __ ] a little debbie
what do you think of that [ __ ] i plugged
actual wendy's [ __ ] she's 91.
still got it
still got it bro it's true what they say
about her
steve from the county's hot seat from
accounting is hot as [ __ ]
he's the hottest yeah
yeah the flip side though
30 million people around the world have
seen your penis
that's it so i would think more people
saw the penis 30 million 30 million
copies were sold that means many more
people will see that yeah they got that
shirt at like target right you know what
i mean like they sell that that yeah
what about like the meme people's now
are all of them gonna sue too there's
like millions and millions eventually
you know what's we know what sucks out
of all this that was a cute baby and
then did you see what he looked like why
the [ __ ] dude he's ugly now man humans
turn out to be so ugly sometimes huh
you're so nice and cute i never knew the
baby was a redhead that honestly breaks
a lot of things for me
i'm growing up you can run it now
honestly yeah not that album anyway
not for me
i mean would you at that time let's say
um because in this situation what had
happened was they were like uh the the
photographer was like a family friend so
they were like a pool party and they
were doing this shoot and then like
photos were taken and then nobody knew
anything that happened and a month later
the baby's photo was blown up on like a
tower records back in the day i'm just
curious how they got that baby to dive
underwater and chase money
well babies they just throw them in
water right yeah some babies just swim
yeah yeah you stole them in the waters
and they just kind of they don't [ __ ]
breathe
in the water they have a what does it
call like a mammalian effect or whatever
where they naturally know how to hold
their breath
and they they they actually unlearn how
to swim uh i think like at one or some
[ __ ] and then you have to re-learn how
to swim how do you do like when you hold
dogs over water and their feet start
because they they were in water for like
nine months yeah so they actually
understand like what it feels like what
i mean i'm chasing money though
i'm pretty sure they also need a baby
they also probably just put it in and
took a photo that could be photoshopped
he was chasing that you can see it yeah
they didn't have photoshop in the 90s
he's chasing that answer i don't think
so
maybe that's subconsciously
for the rest of his life he always saw
himself chasing money and always
understood that so he had to like go get
the money exactly are you trying to
empathize with the coward
no he's just saying that that [ __ ] has
always been greedy yeah he is greedy
so he's always he's always looking for
money he's still looking for money
i'm not surprised i guess i'm not that
surprised that the nirvana baby's still
a big baby you know what i mean
well done is there any fair compensation
would you settle with this guy
who if you're courtney i sue him for not
being cute anymore oh damn because he
should have been yeah it's just so shady
on so many levels because he's not just
suing nirvana
which 15 which is its own entity like
he's like okay how can i milk this
situation let me sue every single person
attaches he should have sued his parents
for child endangerment and being so
stupid and not getting royalties plus
doesn't he know you're not supposed to
[ __ ] with courtney love like we all know
what she's capable of yeah and i'm on
the record right now that's right yeah
wait he's doing courtney love yeah he is
the manager all that stuff she got here
wasn't there a rumor that like she's the
reason why kurt cobain killed himself oh
yeah that was like in the documentary
right oh that's what i'm getting at my
friend wait wait please dive deeper into
that well i there was like a lot of
speculation that courtney love kind of
pushed this guy
into depression and suicide he been sad
have you listened to the music no
there's there's literally like push-ups
the trigger man is according to one of
the documentaries wow yeah really yeah
so she helped she came to him
and yeah so it wasn't a suicide she
wasn't she saw him she shot him that's
the
conspiracy you [ __ ] all these
groupies you son of a [ __ ] yeah
who did she marry afterwards did she
marry somebody afterwards someone famous
i don't remember john leguizamo johnny
was on them really no no no no no i
believe you
i'm sad i believed him whoa so like she
just
killed him and she's walking where did
you see this documentary what is it
called
i think it was on hbo yeah wow it was
the kurt cobain story seattle wanted to
kill themselves so i didn't know also
possibility it's a factor that's what
the statistics say same with london too
right yep oh for sure but they want to
kill themselves just because they live
in london
london fog has nothing to do with the
weather nope
they gotta wake up eat the food
already depressing the streets rough
their bus is all red and stuff their
english breakfast has beans on it beans
and tomatoes i [ __ ] hate beans yeah
bro beans and toast that's one of their
things bro i [ __ ] i hate bees too bro
i hate beans i'm not a big fan of beans
i like beans i wish i could hang out
with you guys right now but
to be honest when you have to eat beans
every day because it's in the cafeteria
it grows on you honestly i do like
breakfast beans pretty good yeah
breakfast i like refried beans i that's
the one beans i hate the most refreshing
the squishy what about the mashem it's
all squishy that's the part where i'm
like what the [ __ ] do you like i don't
like the texture bean and cheese burrito
okay six slices of chicken okay but the
one okay i really like um
no i really like baked beans like
barbecue baked beans oh yeah like those
are british uh breakfast beans are like
that it's like kind of tomatoes it's
like barbecue beans yeah i just like the
texture and i don't want that on toast
london dude [ __ ] lunch
what about a bean and cheese burrito
they smash it i always hate it with no
beans
get a bean cheese bread with no beans
yeah right
prove it so that's a quesadilla girl you
would pick a bean and cheese burrito
over a burrito with meat in it oh no i'm
just saying that bean and cheese
burritos
oh he's exactly right it's not burrito
you never ordered one before because you
you ordered it okay yes yes just admit
it i'm sorry in a burrito form so you
know i ordered a quesadilla with no
cheese and my brother almost hit me
that's at chipotle you can get a
quesarito okay really yeah
yeah you can you can they'll make a
quesadilla and then they'll wrap your
burrito with it wow
you're welcome i can't even eat cheese
right now okay cheese i i'll take it
you're welcome back then i can't either
how come you can't eat cheese not worth
the diarrhea well no i started breaking
out and i didn't break out did you get
eczema from cheese no like
breakfast yeah because i had a pop-up
and we had a whole bunch of leftover
parmesan cheese
and it was just in like a 32 ounce deli
cup and i would just
eat it by the spoonful like i'll make a
bean dip with it so after that like my
face just broke the [ __ ] just eight
spoonfuls of parmesan parmesan cheese
that's right he thought it was the
weirdest [ __ ] ever that is the weirdest
[ __ ] ever it's so good
wait did you melt it and then no no i
melted it in my mouth parmesan is good
bro it's good i've never done that but
i'm intrigued that's like a tree's
friend from a goofy movie the cheese
with these like
like i wish i could still do it
i would it's probably a crazy amount of
umami flavor oh yeah i don't know [ __ ]
about umami bro what are you going to
tell her about umami that scared me
[Laughter]
yeah bro watch your [ __ ] mouth i read
it somewhere watch your [ __ ] mouth
that really did i was like oh [ __ ] he's
about to hit me
you